hey friends it's Justine and today we're
doing a what's on my iPhone 10 now this
is an updated version because I did one
of these when I first got my phone but
when I get a new phone I completely
start over so I basically start from
absolutely nothing so that video was the
first few weeks of when I got my phone
so now obviously many many many months
later I have many many more apps some of
which as I was just scrolling through
here I was like girl you gotta clean
this up like some of this stuff you
don't even use it so here's my first
page we've got the calendar we have
Apple maps Google Maps the clock phone
notes App Store Instagram Twitter
snapchat HQ trivia if you guys haven't
added me on HQ trivia yet just feel free
to download it and be sure to use I just
een as your referral code I still
haven't won at HP trivia like it makes
me very very upset I play so much and
it's just I can't Facebook Amazon Amazon
Prime Apple TV remote which I use it
very very frequently YouTube YT studio
that's an app for creators where we can
get analytics we can edit descriptions
begin edit them nails all kinds of stuff
for people who are creating YouTube
videos settings very important Starbucks
Spotify a last day on earth which is a
really fun game google translate on my
home page because I feel like when I was
traveling to Austria a while ago I was
using this so often that I needed it
front and center fortnight I still
haven't posted any fortnight gameplay I
have to do this for you guys so far the
mobile version is really really fun it's
a lot better than I thought it was I
played for tonight originally on xbox
before it was even the Battle Royale
version that it is now so I feel like I
need to go back and play because I
really really enjoyed that game a lot
next page we have Android wear which I
use with my Michael Kors Android watch
and this folder is the stuff folder
which is all just the Apple standard
apps which are really uninteresting to
me we've got the weather news stocks
reminders iTunes Store iBooks health
wallets photos FaceTime podcast compass
find iPhone find my friends tips
voicemails contacts files over the way
and you get the point
next up we have Netflix Facebook
Messenger Buber venmo Dropbox the Apple
Store app the activity app PayPal clips
Tumblr saucy for those of the drinking
age you can have alcohol delivered to
your doorstep sometimes it gets here
within 15
minutes and it's shocking fancy of
Chardonnay there's an app for that
here's the little games folder which I
feel like needs to be updated because
there are some games on the front page
cookie jam cookie jam blast Jedi
challenges goat simulator best fiends
forever best fiends and the destiny -
companion app PlayMemories mobile this
is what I use to get photos off of my
Sony camera segue 9 BOTS
that's what I use with my little Segway
which I haven't used very often and I
missed that thing we need to bring
hoverboards back Equinox gym I go to
Zillow it's a real estate app quick
that's for creating clips on the GoPro
DJI go for that's for flying my drone
philips hue controlling my lights cube
that's a period app so that's the thing
I love Kinect that's an app that I can
scan a QR code on a treadmill and then
it sinks to my phone to let me know how
fit I am attempting to get 824 that's
what I use to get food delivered to my
house so nose feels linked to music
pocket camp so that's the Animal
Crossing Nintendo game didn't really
play much but what I did at the
beginning it was really fun I love
Animal Crossing and I cannot wait until
they release something for the switch I
will be freaking out GoPro that's the
app that I use to connect to my GoPro
pretty self-explanatory Amazon Alexa
what I use oh shoot sorry sorry sorry
see by GE that's actually the like that
was talking to me because I reset it so
it's telling me to reconnect it Google
Drive lemonade this is like some Hillary
and Trump stickers it also has a bunch
of other stickers that you can download
washoe sand spiffy are both car wash
apps so that people come to your house
and clean your car next door it's like a
neighborhood social network UPS fan day
go caffeine caffeine is actually really
fun I've been working with them for a
while it's a really cool live streaming
platform so if you haven't checked it
out feel free soothe that's an app that
you can get massages at your house
it's crazy living in a big city because
you can honestly find an app for
anything like you can potentially never
leave your house and have everything
delivered to you if that isn't black
mirror I don't know what it
Apple support important American
Airlines post mates on another food
delivery I think we all know what post
mate says Disneyland say use that what
if it doesn't need to see how long lines
are fly Delta swarm it's kind of like a
location-based social network which not
too many people use but me my sister's
still do Southwest this go let's see a
photo editing app which I'm sure many of
you who have heard of tweet bot ubereats
more food delivery OpenTable food
reservations open table restaurant
reservations bitmoji MyFitnessPal jiffy
Brooke Burke body which I've actually
been doing her workouts and I love
Brooke Burke she's probably just oh I
love her she's my favorite video shop
realtor comm box that is the app that
connects to my BitDefender so I can kind
of monitor my home Wi-Fi security OOP
troop make the poop troop probably one
of my most favorite sticker packs moving
on Facebook creator C yes that's what I
was using when I was at sea yes
resi another restaurant reservation
service you guys notice the trend here
like food UAV zones that's an app I use
to see if it's safe to fly my drone in
particular areas mobilepass something
that i used to get back in the country
it's like a mobile passport audible
today's video is not sponsored by
audible by the way verbo and Airbnb I
think you guys all know what Airbnb is
those are basically the same thing arts
and culture that's the Google app that
you can use to take a picture of
yourself and it'll match you with some
sort of piece of history or art that you
look like strange health mate Beck next
to my Nokia scale Chrome
I love hue is a fun little game it's
kind of like a color matching thing bird
you basically can open the app and you
can find a little scooter that is
somewhere nearby you go up to the
scooter open the app click unlock and
then you take the scooter and go and
then you leave the scooter on the side
of the road for the next person yeah
it's a thing Wix thank you guys know
what Wix is that's who is hosting my new
website I just seen calm and I'm sure
many of you guys potentially could have
seen the pre-roll ad of the commercial
before this video if you did raise your
emoji hands GrubHub more food delivery
Yelp lift home kit SoundCloud Pinterest
feedback this is the app that I use to
get feedback because I am running a beta
of iOS on here TG I go Marco Polo Zappos
Google clips
Bloomingdale's Nordstrom headspace it's
cool meditation app British Airways
I always mispronounce
this airline loofa oh man oh I didn't
even tell you guys what's at the bottom
we've got messages email a lot of email
Safari and my camera well thank you guys
so much for watching I would love to
know if you guys have any of the similar
apps that I have are there any apps that
I'm missing that actually definitely
download leave all of your suggestions
in the comments below and I will see you
guys in my next video
[Music]